so where we left off in the last video
we kept trying to approximate this
purple f of X by with a polynomial and
we at first said well let's just make
the polynomial a constant and set it you
know it's just going to intersect F of 0
at X is equal to 0 and so that's what
first you could kind of think of it as a
0 of order approximation of the function
and then we said oh what if not only do
they intersect at X is equal to 0 but
let's say that there's slope is the same
at X is equal to 0 and that's that
approximation and that's about as good
as you're going to do with a line
especially as you get close to 0 we said
ok that's good but what if their second
derivative is the same and that's where
we ended up with we added this term here
and I hinted that we'll just keep doing
this process so I mean you're oh that's
not what I wanted to do we could just
keep doing this process and so you could
imagine if I want their third derivative
to be the same if I want the third
derivative the same I could add another
term right here plus where I know what
the value of f of X is third derivative
is at 0 so f I'll write that as F to the
the third derivative at 0 times X to the
third now what do you think is going to
be down here what's going to the
denominator you might be tempted to say
you might be de tempted to say that that
will put a 3 down here but it turns out
you're gonna have to put a 3 times a 2
which is a 6 or 3 factorial now why is
that why is that well let's just let me
just take a little departure here and I
think you'll start to understand why you
put a 6 down here why this isn't a 3 and
you put a 6 here you put a 2 but 2 is
also 2 factorial right 2 factorial is 2
times 1 right hopefully you remember
what factorial actually let me let me
tell you what factorial is just in case
10 factorial is equal to 10 times 9
times 8 times 7 times 2 times 1 so
you're multiplying all of the numbers up
to that number you know 4 factorial is
he and the numbers get big very very
fast is 4 times 3 times 2 times 1
you know 2 factorial is equal to 2 times
1 1 factorial is equal to 1 and now this
is kind of a weird definition it comes
out of combinatorics and actually it
works for
of what we're doing as well zero
factorial is also equal to one I know
that might be a little on intuitive and
this is just a definition that it's like
saying that I squared is equal to
negative 1 it is a definition but it
work it makes things it makes formulas
be more general I guess is a simple way
to put it but let me erase all of this
because that was just a divergence just
cuz I realized I was going to use two
factorial so you should know the
factorial is but I think that's a fairly
straightforward concept so going back to
what we were doing I was asking you why
do I put a six down here instead of a
three like we put a two here well let's
just take this term alone and take its
third derivative right so if I have this
term and it's you know F the third
derivative at zero X to the third over
let me and let me just write 6 as 3
times 2 or 2 times 3 2 times 3 and
that'll make it a little more clear
what's the what's the first derivative
here what happens when I take the
derivative once well I'm gonna multiply
the whole thing by this exponent and
decrement the exponent right so I'm
gonna multiply the whole thing times 3
times f third derivative x squared over
2 times 3 so that first time I did it
the this 3 and this 3 cancel out all
right that red is looking a little bit
too demonic let me pick another color
okay fine and then when I take the
second derivative what am I gonna get
well the 3 is gone now I just have a 2
in the denominator
right so I multiply the whole thing by 2
times F prime prime prime of 0 times and
I decrement the exponent X to the 1 over
2 well now the twos cancel out right so
the reason why you're putting a
factorial there is every time you take a
derivative you're decrementing the
exponent 1 and multiplying the whole
expression by the exponent so if you're
going to take you know n derivatives
you're essentially going to have to
you're essentially going to be
multiplying this expression times n
factorial and so you you don't want an N
factorial out here you you put an N
factorial at the bottom hopefully that
makes sense play around with it yourself
and it should it should start to to make
a little bit more sense
so in general if we just kept doing this
process forever
what would the function look like what
would the function look like and the
reason why I'm covering this is because
going this way we're going to be able to
prove what I think is the most mind
mind-bending concept in mathematics and
it will make you love mathematics
hopefully some people actually well I
won't go into the spiritual aspects of
it but so so what would be this if I
just kept saying that you know I'm just
gonna keep taking derivatives and and
and adding and adding them to this term
this polynomial
well the polynomial would become P of X
is equal to is equal to F of 0 plus F
prime of 0 X and let's just divide it by
1 factorial just to make it clear that
that's a 1 factorial right and that's an
X to the 1 right that's just this term
but I just wrote it a little differently
and this is that you could almost this
term right here this is f of 0 times X
to the 0 I know that's really messy but
hopefully you see what I'm saying and
that's over 0 factorial right 0
factorial is 1 X to the 0 is 1 so it's
just F of 0 and then plus the second
derivative at 0 times x squared over 2
factorial plus and we just keep adding
the third derivative is the third
derivative at F at X is equal to 0 of X
to the third over 3 factorial and we
just keep keep going on right so we
could do this to infinity and actually
we will do it and this is called the
Maclaurin series so if we just wanted to
approximate this as hard as we can just
actually take the infinite derivatives
of it we get the Maclaurin series we are
going to define this polynomial P of X
it's going to be the infinite series the
infinite sum let's start with n is equal
to 0 and we're going to go to infinity
infinity and what is the each
while the or the turn list of the you
know it's going to be f of what's going
to be F the nth derivative the nth
derivative of F evaluated at zero right
times X to the N over N factorial this
is the Maclaurin series and and we'll
later learn that mcclare the Maclaurin
series is a specific example of the
powers of the Taylor series which is a
specific example of a power series but
anyway this might seem very complicated
to you I have all the Sigma notation
just remember this is essentially just
that and I just keep going to infinity
and if you play around with it makes it
should make sense but I think this will
become a lot more concrete when I do
this with a specific f of X and this is
where it gets cool in case you don't
think it's already cool so let's pick f
of X to be to me the most amazing
function of them all if I ever built
shrine or a church or something or a
skyscraper I would I would somehow make
this this function show up all over the
place and then years from now people
would be it would be awed by the
mysticism of it all but anyway let's try
to approximate e to the X with a
Maclaurin series and you know that Sigma
thing the thing that's hard to memorize
just remember you want all the
derivatives to be the same so let's make
the approximation of this so I'll you
know and we'll actually learn actually I
won't prove it it's out of the scope of
what we're doing right now but the
approximation even when it Senator zero
actually equals the function when you
take the infinite sum but let's just see
what it looks like because this is
pretty cool
well actually let me let me before we
start building the polynomial let's just
figure out a couple of things so what is
so what is what is f prime of X well
that's also e to the X right what's f
prime prime of X well that is also equal
to e to the X right we have learned and
and I actually recently did a proof that
the derivative of e to the X is e to the
X but that always means the second
derivative the third and the fourth and
the nth derivative
of ETA X is equal to EDX right I could
take an arbitrary number of derivatives
of e to the ax and it equals e to the X
which is amazing the rate of change of
the function at at you know any at any
point is equal to the function the rate
of change of the rate of change of the
function at any point is equal to the
function the rate of change it I I want
to just go someplace and ponder it but
I'm too busy making videos but anyway
back to what we were doing so what is F
of 0 F of 0 is just is equal to e to the
0 which is equal to 1 right well that's
also going to be F prime of 0 that's
also e to the 0 which is equal to 1 so f
and all of the derivatives F the nth
derivative at 0 is going to equal 1 for
this specific case of f of X for u the X
and this is why this is so cool
but actually it actually gets even more
amazing so you hopefully realize that f
of X f of 0 and all of its derivatives
at 0 are equal to 1 so now we can do the
powers of the Maclaurin series in the
next video see you soon